hello and welcome my name is Jake I'm
here with - we are the smash bros if you
will of the office both of us have seen
this new trailer for Super Smash Bros
Force which many times now and we're
very very excited oh yeah I think one of
the biggest topics of discussion though
that I've seen mostly pop up is is this
a remaster or is this a brand-new Super
Smash Bros game yeah I mean a lot of
times point to it being a remaster like
Mario Kart Bayonetta like a ton of games
had been ported from the Wii U over to
the switch so it would make sense for it
to be a smash deluxe especially coming
in 2018 that's awfully soon yeah and I
don't know if you remember with 2014 we
were getting trailers and intended
directs leading up to the release of
that game for two years so it 2018 seems
super quick yeah I mean I know they'll
do for more directs and show us some
trailers but I don't know if they can
build a fam hype like they did with that
Wii U one with the sheer amount of
trailer if they're pumping out for it
yeah um one thing though to point out
though is that Sakurai has actually been
working on this game for the last I
think two years is what I've seen in
secret which is big because after smash
2014 he was pretty burnt out yeah it
took quite a toll on his body so for him
to actually come out and say that was
quite surprising yeah also does lead to
the fact that maybe it is a brand new
game like maybe it's something he didn't
want people to get too much hype around
and had it come out all at once yeah and
another thing to point out is the logo
the logo and font a lot of people have
actually pointed this out by now but
they do look different slightly
different but they do look different so
what do you think do you think it's
gonna be remaster or do you think it is
going to be a new Super Smash Bros game
I think it'll be similar to what you
were talking about earlier with splatoon
- I think it will be a brand new game
but it will be very reminiscent to the
Wii U one where it'll be very similar
mechanics probably a lot of the same
characters but it'll be branded at the
brand new smash yeah I'm thinking it'll
it'll be like a yeah like a splatoon to
situation where it's very similar it's
built on the same foundation but it'll
add new characters new stages a new UI
examine the UI and the Wii U one was
pretty messy it was so so that's kind of
where I'm putting my money right now I
don't think it'll be as different as
brawl was - 2014 or melee was to brawl
right or one was to melee of course but
then after watching the true there are
some things we do know about this
already not a lot but there are a couple
things we do know
the big one obviously the Inklings are
in the game right they even let off the
trailer with the Inklings which was a
nice touch because when they first did
that I was like great another splatoon
thing yes like the final announcement is
splatoon right like octo expansion
another splatoon like really it's
between three already yeah but it was
nice to see the smash logo in the eye
showing that you know what we are
getting smashing it yeah being very very
different yeah and something else we saw
we saw breath of the wild link mm-hmm
which has me thinking of a couple
different things could it be another
costume for link could it be another
link because we do have we had young
link at one point we have we think we've
got adult link so do you think it could
be
we have adult link because they can't
get rid of that link right and then a
breath of the wild link or do you think
it'll just be the old link with a new
costume so I think we'll actually get a
brand new link like I think the move set
and like the amount of a variety they
can change with a brand new link would
be kind of cool I thought it might mean
we lose Toon Link or he might lose
youngling yeah I don't think they can
change that link he's he's he's been
there too long but yeah I think we're
gonna get a new link and I think he'll
be using like his up and VOB Rivoli's
gale or something right
so I think that'll be really cool and
just breath of the wild link was so
different in terms of how it's played in
this there's so much to tap into I think
but then there's also some other
returning characters obviously you see
Mario silhouette
I've been in the background there's
another silhouette it's really tough to
pick things out back there right people
have tried but the only ones that I see
are Donkey Kong right and Bowser Bowser
with quite obvious but some people had
mentioned that one of the silhouettes
looked a lot like one of the arms
characters which would make sense the
you know one of the Nintendo's own like
first part first party games so seeing
an arms character would not shock me at
all
yeah it seems like a perfect fit I
probably wouldn't play the arms
character too much but you never know
yeah this game is supposed to come out
in 2018 we mentioned that earlier
my best guess it would be fall I think
in November I think as late as possible
I mean I think that makes sense like the
original Smash Brothers came out in
Japan I believe it was in 1999 so we're
coming really close to the 20 year
anniversary so having it come out and
fall would make total sense to a line
with that 20th anniversary timeline
we've kind of gone over what we've seen
what we think will happen
but what do you hope happens with this
new smash bros game
I mean versed in formulas I hope we get
a ton of new characters like for me
personally I want Gino to make in the
game like Ivan yes I'll one thing that I
hope is that I hope they build off the
new roster rather than kind of pick and
choose like kind of cut ones that they
don't think work anymore they've done
that they kind of do that with Roy right
he was he was out of brawl and they
brought him back in male Erina 2014 and
Mike wolf and snake and stuff like that
I hope they keep everyone in the last
Super Smash Bros game and bring them
over because I'm attached to a lot of
those characters like we've seen it for
example I mean I think it'd be cool if
they actually brought back like every
character who's ever been in the smash
since we are nearing the 20th
anniversary it would be a cool image to
actually see every character who's ever
been in it somehow show up in the
playable option I know the roster be
gigantic at that point but it'd be a
really cool nod to the series yeah I
agree and you also mentioned you also
mentioned using the GameCube controller
- yeah so we found out in October that
GameCube controller support is added to
the switch and you can play a lot of the
games with it so it would make total
sense to have smash capable of playing
to GameCube controller because that is
still to me one of the most ideal way of
playing smash I know you got used to the
pro controller I did but that's because
I couldn't get one of those stupid
really adapter things because they were
in such high demand I mean hopefully
there are much more abundant now but
that definitely seems like the ideal way
to play smash unless they were to make a
brand new controller for it
yeah and finally I think the last thing
that I really hoped for is that they
continue to support this game for a long
time one of the great things about smash
2014 was that they did have DLC they
were adding new characters and that
added a ton of life to the game but I
think it would be so cool if they built
this game with a solid foundation that
they continually update throughout the
switches lifetime add new characters
stages right like that would be ideal
for me like I don't necessarily need a
new smash bros this generation and they
probably won't have a new one after this
so I think if they just continually
update this until the switch is done or
at least for a couple years I would be
in heaven it would be great like I loved
on the Wii U we kept getting those DLC
character he's like even characters like
Bayonetta would add to it and be great
as we're getting more third-party
support for the switch to even see some
of those characters show up in there
like it'd be great to see like shovel
knight in there it'd be great Phoebe
Aneta maker
even cloud from Square Enix and to that
point Gino but just be great to be more
unique character that added to the
roster so finally the last question I
have for you you kind of just talked
about a now especially with Gino but are
there any characters you really want to
see other than Gino in Super Smash Bros
yeah I would actually loved if you snake
make return I thought he was a very
unique addition to brawl a very tough
character to play ad but I love how
different he was and I would love to see
someone like wolf or even king K rool
would be a cool one to see in there yeah
those would all be great additions I
know people are sick of fireman
characters but I'm still holding out
that Tarja from fireman wakening makes
it in because she is spell based and
most the fireman characters use their
swords Raj is cool but that was kind of
getting tiring I don't think that'll
happen I think I don't think they're
gonna be adding any new characters from
awakening right but you never know I'm
excited to see who they come up with
anyway cuz usually what happens is
they'll add a character that I don't
think I like and I'll play on a big oh
wait this is actually one of my favorite
characters I mean what's a new fireman
coming out for the switch it would make
sense to add another fireman character
so yeah it's not far job maybe some
spell based one and hopefully not afford
based one yeah if you want to see more
characters that we'd like to see in
Super Smash Bros we do have a gallery up
on gamespot.com that outlines twenty
characters that we want to see and I
think that about wraps up our discussion
let us know you think are there any
characters you want to see what do you
think is gonna happen is this a remaster
or is this a brand new Super Smash game
[Music]